gentiment on voyage on dit dans la
presse quand vous parlez de cyril et
qu'on reprend souvent des trucs en
disant ouais ce que michael n'aime pas
chez cyril tout ça ça vous gêne vous
trouvez ça juste ou pas juste ce que
mickey n'ayant mais alors ah ouais c'est
la connerie là si tu as fait que des
compliments sur moi d'ailleurs soul et
remercié mika parce que tu as dit que
voilà que tu que tu monsieur faisait
mourir de rire tout en amont et dans
l'interview les gars nous ont nourris
sur mac et est même pas négatif oui je
dis juste - cyril il me fait j'adore
quand vous déconnez j'aime moi quand
céder sur des sujets un peu plus
sérieuse c'est juste ça j'ai même pas 10
j'ai même pas dit j'aime pas j'ai dit
j'aime moins je suis peut-être un peu
moins clients alors que je suis
tellement clients de la rigolade et je
me trouvais trop c'est moche c'est comme
moi de kant quand je parle politique pas
trop et est donc excuse-moi la ta
question c'est est-ce que ça m'énerve
qu'on a appris que c'est toujours ça
alors je n'ai pas du tout le fond du
problème c'est ce que tu avais dit paris
pendant l'interview plus géo et j'avais
dit je suis sûr qu'ils vont garder que
ça va venir après voilà noria des il ya
des choses bien tout ça s'appelle les
[ __ ] à cliquer merci par une question
pour alban moi oui parce que c'est vrai
c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai parce que
maintenant dans l'impression que pour
qu'un film marche il faut qu'ils soient
avec vous vous êtes partout il est
devenu un incontournable connard comment
j'ai tellement été nulle part pendant
longtemps
[Rires]
je ferai c'est vrai que là elle on a
toujours su que telle et telle est
partout battue m'a encouragé et la
buvette où on s'arrête a cru en moi et
me tais toi
non mais c'est vrai sur france 4 dès je
te sens bien
on a enfin donné seul fait de roxio
fessionnels